fungos no intestino faz perder peso e
qual é o melhor tratamento bem a
presença de fungos no intestino
especialmente a cândida pode influenciar
o peso de várias maneiras geralmente
aumenta o peso mas pode acontecer também
de perder o peso então vamos lá a
infecção por fungos da classe da cândida
especialmente levam a disbiose
intestinal que a gente chama de cifo né
que é Cido de proliferação de fungo no
intestino Então tem um desequilíbrio na
flora intestinal isso vai levar sintomas
como dor abdominal diarreia constipação
e até mesmo alterações de metabolismo e
na absorção de nutrientes isso vai
indiretamente afetar o peso além disso a
presença de fungos vai aumentar a
inflamação intestinal alterar a resposta
imunológica que pode levar muitas vezes
ao ganho de peso mas é possível sim Pero
de peso devido a mudança no apetite e na
metabolização dos alimentos Então os
sintomas de uma infecção fúngica
intestinal eles incluem dor abdominal
flatulência né excesso de gases diarreia
ou constipação ou mesmo os dois
alternados fadiga e problemas de pele
enxaqueca ou alergias então o tratamento
para infecções fúngicas intestinais
geralmente envolve uma abordagem
integrativa que vai combinar mudança de
estilo de vida uso de antifúngicos seja
naturais ou não e suplementos eh que vão
ser necessários para restaurar a saúde
intestinal então em termos de mudança
estilo de vida uma dieta rica em
alimentos naturais mas que
temporariamente você vai ter que tirar
por exemplo frutas doces vai ter que
tirar alimentos fermentados
temporariamente porque eles pioram esses
quados de cifo então reduzir o consumo
de açúcar refinado até zerar é muito
importante de carboidratos simples
porque eles alimentam o crescimento dos
fungos beber bastante água evitar o
consumo excessivo de álcool e praticar
atividade física regular para melhorar a
saúde intestinal e o suplementos que
você vai utilizar o óleo de coco vai ser
interessante que tem efeito antifúngico
os probióticos que vão restaurar o
equilíbrio da flora intestinal o extrato
de alho o extrato de orégano tem efeitos
antifúngicos também o extrato de casca
de homo branco também bem interessante
em casos mais graves pode ser necessário
o uso de medicamentos antifúngicos como
é o caso por exemplo da Nistatina ou
Fluconazol ou outros tipos de fúngicos
Ok então abordagem funcional integrativa
também pode incluir testes para
identificar a presença de fungos e
outras di BIOS intestinais como exames
intestinais especiais como compren
digestive to analysis né E também tem
vários outros testes que você pode estar
utilizando como de ácidos orgânicos
urinários então técnicas de redução de
estresse meditação e yoga sempre ajudam
e tenha sempre em mente que você vai ter
que fazer um acompanhamento com o médico
e nutricionista para poder melhorar de
sintomas